COFFEY, OH MY GOODNESS!!
3.2 ON THE SHOT CLOCK
>> Jim: THE BEST PART OFS.
HAMMER TIME!
EXTENDED MINUTES TONIGHT.
HE'S UP
TWENTY-NINTH IN THE LEAGUE AT
THREE-POINT ATTEMPTS.
NO, DON'TPOINTS IN
THE GAME.
FRANZHOW HARD WHEN
DELL  WE
HAVEDominique:
OKLAHOMA STATE.
>> RICHARD: LET'S GO PREMATURE N
HE GETS THIS, A LOT OF GUYS
WOULD LIGHT UP I HAV
11-0, ATLANTA.
FIRST ON TARGET.
THEYGOOD STEEL.
MAN.
LOOK AT THAT. TO TAKE ACCOU
HE IS ON TOP.
YOU CAN SEE HIS HEELS  THE
TIME-OUT. LINE.
DONCIC AGAINSTST
>> DANIEL GAFFORD GOODNESS.
HE'S GOING TO RIDE THE STON
>> Stacey: SAYING GET OUT OF
TO GRIMES.
THROWS IT UP.
THE ONE YOU CAN BE
A LITTLE BIT OFF TARGET TOO, I
>> Jason: BAM ADEBAYO
SOMEBODY IS WATCHING.
A LOT OF
BOL BOL WAS GETTING A TONGUE